the republican party is now overtly a
christian nationalist party now the
important word here is overtly because
they've actually been a christian
nationalist party for a long time think
back you may recall
during the lead-up and uh during the
invasion of iraq in 2003
then president george w bush said that
god came to him with tears in his eyes
and said sir no i added that part god
came to him and said you should do this
you should invade
many times we hear policy supported or
opposed by republicans on the basis of
what is in the particular
sacred text that their particular
religion follows all of these are
elements of how these republicans would
like to see the country run
and the way they would like to see the
country run is with a sort of mix of
government and christianity now it's not
just government and religion generally
it's not government and islam it's not
government and judaism although they
will kowtow to that by saying our
judeo-christian values although remember
that jews are the most behind black
folks liberal voting group in the united
states sometimes as liberal as black
folks so the idea of judeo-christian
values is actually a cover it's a red
herring and they've been doing it for
decades so the word overtly is the
important word because now they are
brazen enough to just say it and we've
talked before about
what do we mean by christian nationalism
christian nationalism is the belief that
the united states as a country is
defined by christianity
that the government should actively
keep the country christian and keep
christianity at the center of government
many christian nationalists will
actually say that it would no longer be
america if it were no longer a christian
nation and that christianity should have
a privileged position in the public
square and it does by the way i mean at
a very superficial level
one religion gets federal holidays and
that's christianity that that's the one
out of hundreds or thousands of
religions that's the one
and thus it does have a privileged place
in american society already they used to
have to be a little bit more subtle in
their christian nationalism but no more
here are some examples from just the
last few weeks here's donald trump over
the weekend in tampa florida at the
turning point usa event talking about
americans kneel to god we are americans
and we kneel to god well not everybody
does actually and some kneel to
different gods or no god at all we will
not break we will not yield we will
never give in
we will never give up
we will never ever ever back down
as long as we are confident in united
the tyrants we are fighting
do not stand a chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and god alone
we also looked at marjorie taylor greene
radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green saying i'm a
christian nationalist that's not bad
it's actually a good thing
now if the republican party becomes a
party that actually does the same does
the things we say we're about then we
are going to be a party for nationalism
isn't that right wow
i mean she's not wrong right like it's
true they talk about the importance of
christianity in civil government and
she's saying we shouldn't just talk
about it we should act on it and she's
accurately assessing that if they acted
on the things they said we're talking
about a christian nationalist country
but then i think there's another element
we need to have and i'm a christian how
many christians do we have here
[Music]
so you see i also call myself a
christian nationalist
and that's not a bad word
that's actually a good thing right and
there's nothing wrong with leading with
your in with your faith because we
should lead with our faith because if
we're doing that then we're doing the
right thing doesn't mean we're perfect
it just means we're doing the right
thing okay
and then also lauren bobert i mean it's
all a very very similar line lauren
beaubert at some
backyard farmyard farm speech or you
know who knows where this was
saying that it is actually important for
churches to teach
how to influence and direct government
and i believe that great patriots all
throughout this nation
and christians will begin to position
themselves
in these days and these times that
pastors would have a boldness to speak
from the pulpit of their churches to
direct and inform the church on how to
influence the direction of government
and then even more overtly she's tired
of this separation of state of church
and state junk and i know some of you
have seen this clip a couple of times
now but it's important to include it
here because it is so overt the reason
we had so many over
reaching regulations in our nation is
because the church complied
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does
now it actually is right there and it is
a
one of the top line elements of the
structure of the united states congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof it's right
there and they love to play these games
with well it's not really what the
founders meant and they were all
religious and they were christian and so
on and so forth this is one of the most
dangerous movements currently going and
unfortunately it has more oxygen than it
has in a very long time they openly now
are touting this ideology uh christian
revolt
revival christian nationalism using
their religiosity to justify homophobia
to justify transphobia to justify
sometimes racism to justify demeaning or
putting in positions uh subservient
positions other religions which is
certainly not what the founding fathers
meant so this is another layer you've
got
to go back a little bit we have like the
neocon
spread democracy layer of right wing ism
that's less present right now but it
could come back at any time that was
more under like the bush administration
you have the sort of wacky
reactionary trumpest
layer to this right wing movement which
is still present and may come back full
force depending on what happens in 2022
and 2024 but then you have the christian
nationalist element which is just as
dangerous and it is so fundamentally at
odds with what the united states is
supposed to be so what do we do well
we've got to vote i mean it's i know
it's at this point it feels almost like
not enough and also like really that's
also the solution there yeah i mean if
these people aren't in power they can't
do it it's that simple and of course
they're trying to
between gerrymandering and election uh
manipulation i guess is what we're
calling it now um they are trying to
take control even when they don't win so
just another reason why
uh the 2022 midterms are arguably the
most important that i can remember
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping